I think there is already a lot of
collaboration going on between European
countries and China and between US and
China and this is necessary from so many
different perspectives China is part of
WTO
it is a the major you know economy
gradually will be and it's a it's in the
sustainable development and climate area
it is essential for the global future so
no doubt there has to be collaboration
and China is going to develop they are
they have ambitions and we have to
realize that those ambitions are not
different from the ambitions that
dominated in our own countries when our
countries were being developed and new
technologies were being put into
function so the best thing we can do is
to be collaborative and see to it that
the patterns that are used are inspired
by future looking technologies and it
will benefit all of us
I you know this being is so afraid about
competitiveness I have never understood
even as a prime minister I mean unless
you have products or services to sell to
others outside your own country then you
better look for other things that you
can do better we we live in a in a world
where we all benefit from doing what we
are best at doing and and use our minds
and our efforts to promote a development
action that benefits all of us so this
you know this drama about being so
scared about everybody else
I have never you know really taken on
board
you